[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre de la Santé 500
jours 500 jours c'est le nombre de jours
qu'il nous reste avant la cérémonie
d'ouverture des Jeux olympiques de Paris
la parade nautique ou des fils ronds les
10000 athlètes sur 6 km est un lourd des
filles en matière de sécurité le budget
que leur annoncé maîtrisée à hauteur de
8 milliards d'euros sans de plus en plus
difficile à tenir et la France n'a pas
droit à l'erreur mais ma question porte
sur une autre difficulté celle qui
concerne la situation et la capacité
d'accueil des hôpitaux pendant que ce
dérouleront les Jeux Olympiques cet été
pour ce qui concerne les 15000 athlètes
et ceux qui les accompagnent un centre
de santé sera créé en lien avec la PHP
mais pour ce qui concerne les plus de 10
millions de visiteurs attendus que
compte faire le gouvernement les
hôpitaux de Parisiens ont en normal
peine à fonctionner les services
d'urgence sont débordés et trop de lits
de chirurgie sont aujourd'hui fermés
ajoutons de surcroît qu'en plein été en
raison des congés les équipes médicales
sont réduites gouverner c'est prévoir
alors Monsieur le Ministre qu'avez-vous
prévu pour assurer le fonctionnement des
hôpitaux parisiens pour faire face aux
soins courants et à l'affût de visiteurs
pendant les Jeux Olympiques merci pour
vos réponses la parole et communiste de
la santé de la prévention Monsieur
François Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice puissant autour de la première
ministre le gouvernement est totalement
mobilisé autour de la ministre des
Sports pour faire de la Coupe du monde
de rugby également mais des Jeux
Olympiques bien entendu et par olympique
la grande fête sportive qui doivent être
alors dans ce cadre plus global mon
mystère est concentré sur trois points
vous en avez appelé un jean préciserai
deux autres le premier c'est bien sûr de
maintenir l'accès aux soins l'accès aux
soins sur les territoires concernés par
les Jeux Olympiques que ce soit à
l'Île-de-France mais n'oublions pas
aussi les hauts de France et PACA qui
vont être directement concernés cet
accès aux soins il est pour les
Franciliens par exemple bien entendu des
gens qui habitent à côté des sites
olympiques et pour cela nous mobilisons
le public le privé la médecine libérale
l'ensemble de nos partenaires pour
pouvoir assurer cette réponse qui a
évaluée vous parliez des services
d'urgence nous évaluons à plus 5% de
fréquentation pendant cette période à
titre d'exemple
les trois autres publics sont
particulièrement alterner nous sommes
attentifs au touristes qui vont arriver
à ce moment-là il y a des questions de
prise en charge bien sûr financière mais
il y a aussi des questions de traduction
qu'il faut prendre en compte les
sportifs et leur staff ont des parcours
de soins qui vont être identifiés pour
une croisent pas les publics de
spectateurs et puis enfin les personnes
en situation de handicap doivent
bénéficier de parcours de soins
parfaitement identifié le deuxième point
que nous travaillons c'est celui des
situations sanitaires exceptionnelles le
risque climatique nous serons en été les
risques infectieux les risques
énergétiques et le risque également de
cybersécurité de cyber-racades avec la
mise en place de contre-mesures enfin le
troisième point c'est celui de
l'héritage des Jeux Olympiques cet
héritage c'est le sport santé le
président de la République a annoncé que
2024 le sport serait grande cause
nationale dans ce cadre-là le
déploiement encore plus important du
sport santé en termes de prévention
puisque c'est un axe fort de la
politique de mon ministère va nous
permettre d'améliorer l'état de santé
globale de nos concitoyens voici les
trois axes sur lesquels nous travaillons
actuellement de façon extrêmement
précise je vous remercie
que le ministre vous l'avez compris ma
question est légitime est préventive
légitime parce que le personnel de santé
s'inquiète préventive parce que les
Français ont trop souffert du fiasco du
Stade de France à l'occasion de la
finale de la Ligue des champions alors
c'est vrai que mesdames et messieurs les
ministres comme le président de la
République nous souhaitons des médailles
mais nous souhaitons surtout être sur
les plus hautes marges du podium en
matière d'organisation organisation des
Jeux Olympiques organisations de la
santé pendant les Jeux Olympiques
organisation de la santé aussi dans nos
territoires et dans nos départements au
quotidien pour tous les Français